SIA tweets her own naked photo we also
got played by Diddy Plus we're with the
cast of Marvel's The Punisher hello from
New York friends I got to admit this
Cali boy is cold but thankfully I just
see his epic move against a paparazzo to
warm my soul now the Australian singer
won't show her face but she's got no
problem between her bare behind once she
learned that posture trying to sell nude
pics of her on Monday the 41 year old
beat the paparazzi to the punch tweeting
out a screenshot of one of the pictures
writing someone is apparently trying to
sell naked photos of meats in my fans
save your money
here it is for free every day is
Christmas now for obvious reasons I
can't show you the photo but you get it
see is naked and she tweeted it out I
cannot get over this epic move and
neither can her fans or her famous
friends see his Muse Kate Hudson
actually commented on that same
Instagram post writing oh man I love you
I got to agree file this under SIA is
perfect alright in other news we got
punked by Diddy or Puff Daddy there's a
puffy what is his name Sean Combs shook
the Internet over the weekend cleaning
that he changed his name to love aka
brother love I got to admit I bought it
we showed you guys that video yesterday
and today he says it was all a joke
hello is it me you're looking for well
ladies and gentlemen today I've come to
the conclusion that you cannot play
around with the Internet due to an
overwhelming response from the media out
there
and just due to their not wanting to be
any confusion I was only joking okay I
then changed my name it's just part of
one of my alter egos my alter egos his
love but to set the record straight
because I have a lot of press to do the
next couple of weeks you could address
me by hate my older names and but if you
still want to call me love me love baby
but I was only playing fool me once
shame on you fool me twice shame on me
but apparently we can call whatever you
want I don't know I can't keep up are
you guys and finally come into Netflix
in November in just a couple of weeks is
Marvel's The Punisher the Marvel
spin-off wasn't even on the streaming
services radar until Jon Bernthal turn
as the marine vet turn vigilante popped
up in Marvel's daredevil well John is
now anchoring the series and I caught up
with him and the rest of the cast at
last night's New York premiere about how
the show will tackle the dark storyline
when Marvel first introduced the
Punisher in the 70s I mean it was really
response to the times how does your
character in this series address what's
going on now
I mean look I think you don't look this
is a crazy time right now and I mean
let's be honest we know we pushed back
the premiere of this show in the wake of
the tragedy in Las Vegas come home
yesterday to look at the news and see
what happened in Texas and you know it
breaks my heart my heart is my heart is
broken and I can't imagine what it's
like to be in that small town everyone's
affected and I love that we don't shy
away from them we don't take sides on
them but especially as a woman in that
story to be a part of that conversation
we're not usually given the opportunity
we're given the lighter romantic stuff
and to be a part of that discussion was
very meaningful to me I think the job of
art when it's good is to hold a mirror
to society and to make a make you
question society it's not it's not its
job to answer the questions it's job to
make you ask it I do think that all
sides of the debate are brought up in
this show and I think there's merit on
both sides and I think people have to
sort of abandon the rigor in which
everybody sticks to their side of the
position and start talking to each other
start figuring this thing out I started
meeting that our country has a very deep
problem right now because this just
keeps coming and my heart's broken as a
father as a man and as an American the
cast actually echoed that sentiment
saying that it's important for the show
to start this kind of dialogue I
actually watched the first episode and I
gotta say it's actually really poignant
but you still get everything you know
and love from our whole project The
Punisher hits Netflix starting November
17 all right that's it for now from the
Big Apple you guys be sure to like and
share this video and ring the bell so
you don't miss tomorrow's daily denne
until then taxi